So a major interest that we have in our
lab is understanding immunological memory
to the infections that we have gotten as
children or even as adults or the
vaccines that we get as children immunological memory is the ability of the
immune system to respond much faster
upon re-exposure to the same pathogen
and that's the basis of vaccination so
if you get as a child you get a
polio vaccine or a measles or mumps
vaccination and you're protected from
that disease for many many years
sometimes for life and the reason for
that is because you've got memory you've
got t-cells and b-cells that recognize
that pathogen and will protect you
immediately upon re-exposure to that
pathogen so our lab has been interested
understanding how long-term immune
memory or immunologic memory is
maintained after either infection or
vaccination so what we'll cover in our
in my presentation today are four things
first I'll talk to you about logical
memory then I'll talk to you about in
particular the properties of memory
t-cells
what makes memory t-cells do what they
do which is protect us from infections
or in rapidly respond so a something
about the properties of memory t-cells
and then I will switch to what for us
was a very exciting line of research
which is what happens if there's a
chronic infection so start with them
logical memory then talk about
functional memory t-cells you get after
an acute infection or vaccination and
then tell you about what happens if
there is a chronic persistent antigenic
stimulus as you have during chronic
infections or in the conditions of a
cancer with the constant stimulation met
humor antigen and then I'll tell you
about a inhibitory receptor that
actually results in dysfunction of these
t-cells during a chronic infection or in
a tumor setting so it's like a break
that comes on and keeps them from being
functional and then I'll talk to you
about how you can restore function in
these cells by releasing that
that break and then I'll end by the
clinical implications in treatment of
cancer of using the PD one directed
immunotherapy
so what I shared with you today
some studies that we have done on
understanding t-cells memory in
particular cytotoxic CD8 t-cells memory T
cells are composed of two major subsets
the CD4 t-cells which provide help for
antibody responses predominantly and
then you have CD8 t-cells these are T
cells that recognize infected cells and
can kill these infected cells
a CD8 t-cell is the best mechanism that
we have are the best soldiers that we
have to eliminate either virally
infected cells or tumor cells so this is
a very important way of eliminating your
infected cells the CD8 t-cells can
actually they will attach to the
infected cell or to the tumor cell they
do this because the t-cell receptor will
recognize peptides they can either be
tumor antigen peptides or they can be
peptides coming from the virus for
example if the cell is infected with HIV
there will be peptides from the HIV
virus which are expressed
presented by MHC class 1 molecules on
the cell surface so here you've got a
piece of the bar a peptide sticking on
the surface of the infected cell you've
got a t-cell which recognizes that
particular peptide presented by the MHC
class 1 molecule that interaction will
result in that t-cell then killing that
infected cell and so the CD8 t-cells are
referred to as cytotoxic CD8 t-cells or
CD8 t-cells are these difference so when
I talk now in for the next 15 minutes or
so I will use these terms
interchangeably I might say CTL and I
might say CD8 t-cell but it's the same
thing a cell that can kill that
eliminate a virally infected cell so we
use this mouse model of acute infection
to study the properties of memory CD8 T
cells and what we found was that memory
CD8 t-cells basically can live for the
life of the mouse after vaccination or
after the infection is cleared and we
have then extended these studies in
humans and shown that people who got the
smallpox vaccine even 78 years ago
have memory CD8 t-cells that recognize
that the smallpox virus so long-term T
cell memories maintained not only in
mice but also in humans and can last for
literally 50 years or longer so you get
D so then the question was how are these
t-cells maintained and work that we did
along with other people showed that the
t-cells are maintained two ways one they
are actually intrinsically very
long-lived
they can live for many many years and
most of the time they're just very quiet
they're not dividing there's a setting
Esquires themselves likewise sent I mean
they're not replicating or dividing the
sitting as a cell that's in a g0 g1
phase but they also undergo what we and
others have termed a homeostatic
proliferation that is they have a stem
cell like property where they can
self-renew
so every few months in a mouse and every
few years in a human the it there's a
capacity of these cells to self renew
they will undergo another division to
maintain the numbers so there's a slow
attrition or death of these cells
there's also a slow birth of these cells
that maintains numbers at fairly
constant levels for many many years so
this is one intrinsic property of a
memory t-cells it can self renew itself
and that's how it's maintained for such
a long period the other very interesting
property of memory t-cells is that when
they now see the infecting pathogen -
what the which they were they can
recognize they make a very rapid
effector response and we're dealing here
with cytotoxic CD8 t-cells so even
though this memory cell is very looks
like a very quiet cell sitting without
any replication as soon as it sees the
invading pathogen to which it which it
can recognize it very rapidly elaborates
effector function and what I mean by
effector function is that it can now
very rapidly kill that cell so a memory
cell has two properties which are very
different from that of a naive so there
is one that has not gotten this program
of being a memory cell one it's much
longer lived intrinsically it has the
capability of the soma static
proliferate
to maintain its numbers and it has the
ability to elaborate effector function
very rapidly and that's the basis that's
the cellular basis of memory by CD8
t-cells so while we were doing these for
many years my lab has been interested in
this question for almost 30 years now I
was at UCLA when we first started these
studies and then I moved to Emory
University in 1995 and for the last 20
years we have been continuing these
fundamental Studies on t-cell memory
both in animal models and in humans and
obviously these have a lot of
implications in terms of optimizing and
developing different vaccines
it's also one of the challenges in
research is how do you pick a topic how
do you pick a model what I think here
that the key thing is you should ask an
important question you should ask a
question that a lot of people are
interested in they should ask a question
that has broad implications and that's I
think we were lucky I was or I should
say I was the kid that when I started my
lab I asked a question that perhaps was
a good question to ask and the question
I asked was how do you maintain a
logical memory to an infection you got
or a vaccine you got 20 years ago or 30
years ago in 50 years ago how does this
memory maintain so I think the question
was a very good one but then you Sefton
that but the next stage is how do you
study that question and I would the
advice I would give is pick a model
where you can really study the question
the way you can really dissect it you
can understand it in some detail so we
again I think made a good choice we
picked a mouse model sometimes people
don't like what you learn from mice and
they not everything you learn they're
extrapolates into humans but still I
think if you ask the right question do
it well those discoveries won't hold as
you move up towards human studies again
so we picked a mouse model and why you
pick that particular mouse model we
picked it because that was a natural
this virus that we used which because F
CMV is a natural pathogen of mice it in
fact it's you can find wild mice in the
nature which are infected with this of
course we were not working with those
mice we're working with mice in the lab
that we infected with LCM B but the
reason I emphasize the there it's a
mouse virus is pathogens evolve with its
own host so when if you're studying a
mouse virus in a mouse you re looking at
the interaction between a virus and its
natural host and this is a much better
than sticking a human virus that doesn't
replicate in my saw replicates poorly so
if you want to discover fundamentals of
immune responses do it with a natural
host natural
pathogen and the virus that will
replicate efficiently and give you the
all the things that you need to study in
terms of viral infections so I think
it's picking the model and then you ask
the right questions in this case it was
you know I should right that's questions
I should say you should then study what
you want to look at in as much detail as
you can and again the mouse model allows
you to do this in this particular one
reagents were available for analyzing
the t-cells reagents were available to
look at what the virus was contributing
so it was a well-defined model for
studying immune responses to two
borrowed infection and then it's
interesting how science moves forward it
depends on how technology is being
developed so our lab was never
developing new technology we were real
immunologists more I would say
biologists fear viola just asking
biological questions we are not we were
not creating any tools and any reagents
but others where the science moves
forward because many people do many
great things so we were greatly helped
in many different things so I mentioned
to you that we did this gene expression
profiling
of course that we didn't develop them
but those tools became available tools
became available worked in other places
in terms of looking at at the
appropriate single cell assays developed
to look at expression of different
cytokines so the techniques and reagents
that develop one of the most important
reason that was developed Baxley was
worked at john altman who's a faculty
member at emory vaccine center did when
he was at stanford university as a
postdoc and that was the development of
these MHC class when tetramers these are
reagents that you can use to identify
specifically t-cells reacting against
different viruses so this development of
the tetra Murray agent greatly helped in
the analysis that we did so my advice
there is that as you ask the right
question pick the right model and be
aware of all the wonderful technology
that's developing around you because you
have to apply then the state-of-the-art
techniques no matter who's developed it
you don't need to be an expert in it you
just bring the technique in
to your lab or you collaborate with
those people and move it
what happens if instead of day
infection or a good vaccine that gives
you this long lived memory responses
what will happen if you have a
persistent infection that is you have a
chronic infection like you have in HIV
or hepatitis B virus infection or
hepatitis C virus infection or you would
have in many tumors because the tumor
antigen is there continuously so in an
acute infection setting where the t-cell
is stimulated for a short period it gets
all the right cues and gets all the
right buttons are pushed so you generate
these highly functional memory cells
what would happen if that antigen does
not disappear and continues to stimulate
the t-cell
we made the discovery that t-cells are
functionally exhausted it was known look
that actually we had done and many other
people had done is that if there is a
chronic infection and you look at you
tried to measure a t-cell or even
sometimes Abby's ever certainly when try
to measure a t-cell response against
that particular chronic infection you
couldn't detect those cells by
functional assays and because that were
the only asset available and the
assumption was that either the t-cells
are not there or they were never
generated so the fact that there was a
decreased immune response against a
chronic pathogen was known in fact we
had published a paper on this many years
back in the 1980s but the basis for that
this non-responsiveness was not known
and most people had assumed that the T
cells were not there that they were
deleted in fact that was a favorite
hypotheses that that you delete antigen
reactive t-cells or self reactive T
cells in the thymus and they also you
have really this kernel deletion and you
don't have the t-cells or this or the
virus did something to inhibit the
generation of this t-cell response so
immune suppression by the virus to
inhibit the response or the deletion of
these cells made the two major
mechanisms for not being able to control
a chronic infection and that of course
also extended to the tumor setting so we
then again modeled these studies in in
the mouse model that we use to study the
good memory cell generation so when and
then we got a very interesting result we
found that when there is a chronic
antigenic stimulation the t-cells
actually get functionally exhausted and
and that was a paradigm shift because
the if the t-cells are there that means
you can try and fix things if they're
dead there's nothing you can do if they
were not generated there's not a whole
lot that you can do so that was a
paradigm shift in terms of showing that
the t-cells are physically present but
they're dysfunctional so the t-cells are
physically present but now they're no
longer able
kill the infected target cell they are
no longer able to secrete cytokines
which have antiviral activities both the
cytokine ability the ability secrete
cytokines which have antiviral effect
that's lost as well as the ability to
kill the cells as lost and also their
ability to proliferate and expand
greatly after antigen stimulation is
lost so we define so this ours was the
first group to define this t-cell
exhaustion this was a paper we published
in 1998 actually this is a paper that
was published from Emory University
Alan's a AK who was a postdoc in the lab
made this discovery that t-cells are
present but they are dysfunctional and
are functionally exhausted yes one of
the one of the joys I should say of
science is that if you kind of make an
interesting discovery and then see how
it moves forward so for us the t-cell
exhaustion part that Alan say Acme were
really there was excitement in the lab
that we had made this discovery and
allowing the possibility of maybe fixing
these cells and then when Dan Barbara
did really that but I think with truly
seminal experiments with the blockade
there was huge huge excitement in the
lab dan was really excited everyone in
the lab was excited that we could do
something so simple whoo the experiment
was very very simple we had a
chronically infected mouse and all Dan
did was he injected some antibody to the
mouse very unsophisticated experiment
that anybody could do that's the single
injection and then the result really was
quite was quite striking after we
reported the finding that t-cells become
functionally exhausted during chronic
stimulation in this mouse model several
other investigators at other places and
also at Emory University showed that the
same finding of t-cell exhaustion occurs
in human infections so it was then shown
that people who are infected with HIV
have HIV specific CD8 t-cells in their
blood that you can easily detect that
even in their lymph nodes when some limb
from biopsies
but they are not able to kill the target
self so they become dysfunctional other
investigators showed the same thing in
chronic hepatitis C virus infection
hepatitis B virus infection so that
became very quickly established that
human chronic viral infections like HIV
HCV HPV which have very high levels of
antigen high levels of virus and persist
for the life of the individual unless
they get treated with appropriate drugs
okay you get this t-cell dysfunction
also people at around the same time who
were working in cancer models t were
models in mice showed the same thing
they showed that there is t-cell
dysfunction in the t-cells that
infiltrate the tumor these cells are
referred to as tumor infiltrating
lymphocytes tells as the abbreviation
that's used so it was shown that tails
also have this t-cell dysfunction
because of the chronic stimulation by
the tumor antigens and then oncologists
who were working with human cancer
patients found the same thing so this
phenomenon of t-cell exhaustion which
was first described in this mouse model
of that we use sa virus called
lymphocytic Korea meningitis virus you
don't need to know worry about what the
name is and what it does it can infect
humans it has its really of not.but
significance there is a wonderful mouse
model to study many different aspects
billion systems so these studies which
came out of this LC MB mouse model of
t-cell exhaustion we quickly extended
into human cancer t-cells and in human
chronic viral infections
the next question was what is the
mechanism of this t-cell exhaustion why
are these t-cells not able to kill the
target cells why they're not able to do
what the good memory central so the
contrast here was with the highly
functional memory cells with the
dysfunctional cells and the chronic
infection so what we then decided to do
was that we said let us look at the gene
expression profiling of a highly
functional memory cell and compare it to
that of the highly dysfunctional cell
and the system that we used allowed us
to take t-cells of the same specificity
and what I mean by that is it's a t-cell
which has a t-cell receptor but sees the
same peptide from the virus that we're
studying but one was under the
conditions of an acute infection and the
cells are highly functional another is
under conditions of the chronic
infection where the cells are
dysfunctional so we're not comparing
apples and oranges we'd be comparing
different flavors of the same fruit and
so we looked at the 20,000 plus genes
which are expressed by these cells and
we found that there were some striking
differences in the gene expression
profiling of the exhausted cells
compared to the functional cells and
there are many many differences but what
we were struck with and that was the
thing that really was the most
differentially expressed between these
two cells where was the expression of
inhibitory receptors so there are
inhibitory receptors that a cell can
express and these intimate receptors
actually inhibit t-cell receptor
signaling t-cell receptor is what
recognizes the tumor cell or the
infected cell and it's signaling to the
t-cell receptors needed for the cell to
then kill the target cell so these are
inhibit receptors that come up and are
regulating that t-cell receptor and the
most striking receptor that we
identified in terms of t-cell exhaustion
was a molecule called PD one PD one
strands for programmed cell death one
this was a gene that was cloned by
tasuku Hanzo in Japan in the early 1990s
Dean had been around for a long time but
its function in terms of chronic
infections its function in terms of
t-cell exhaustion was not normal so our
studies identified that this molecule
was expressed at very high levels on
these dysfunctional or exhausted CD8
t-cells but then what really clinched
the deal here was in a collaborative
study with gordon freeman who's a
scientist at dana-farber Cancer
Institute at Harvard Medical School
Gordon Freeman had antibodies that could
bind the inhibitory receptor and the way
the municipal works is that the speedy
one will bind to a ligand that's either
on the tumor cell or on the infected
cell this ligand is known as PD n1l
standing for lanyons it's a it's a
molecule that will bind the inhibitory
receptor so what Gordon had made was
antibodies that would either bind the
inhibitory receptor or the ligand and
prevent the block interaction between
these two so if you prevent interaction
of the PD one which is on the t-cell the
PDL one which is on your target cell if
that interaction is blocked then the
inhibition does not happen and the
results we got were really quite
striking we showed that if you take a
chronically infected Mouse and you
infuse this Mouse to inject into these
mice antibody either against the
inhibitory receptor or against the
ligand disrupting that inhibitor
interaction suddenly now you restore
function back in the cells the cells
begin to expand because they have the
TCR stimulation they are able to kill
the virally infected cells secrete
antiviral cytokines and most importantly
bring about a reduction of the viral
load so this was the first demonstration
that this blockade of the speedy one
pathway in vivo and the condition
electronic infection will restore
function back into the t-cells and
result in viral in
control of the viral infection so this
finding had a huge impact this work was
done actually by a graduate student at
Emory University then Barbara what what
happens not antigen disappears and this
paper attractive does not recipient
continues Force Unleashed so before we
six immediately there was a flurry of
papers that came and some of those B
were involved in collaborating with our
friends showing that BB one also is
involved in inhibiting HIV specific
t-cells and this was a study we did with
Bruce while what could happen that
antigen design then in studies that we
did at embryos that's not busy who's a
faculty member at the Emory vaccine
Center are assured that the same thing
happens in HCV infected people people
who are chronically in trade with
hepatitis C virus do have CD8 t-cells
that recognize HCV but they have very
high levels of pd-1
on on their cell surface and that
inhibits the function of those t-cells
others showed the same thing with
hepatitis B and so on so basically is
very quickly established not that t-cell
exhaustion as I told you happens in many
chronic infections but now it has also
shown that a major regulator of the
t-cell exhaustion is this inhibitory
receptor pd-1 and that blockade of this
interaction results in functioning in
those cells so think of it as a break
that's coming on the t-cells so that the
t-cell receptor you're pressing so
you're pressing the accelerator because
there's antigen stimulation but the
break is on so basically nothing nothing
happens and releasing pd-1 is releasing
a break on the t-cells
and people who were working in tumor
systems also made the similar
observation that vd1 is a major target
in on the tills
these tumor infiltrating lymphocytes
that get into the tumor but cannot kill
the tumor have very high levels of pd-1
then there was a lot of interest in
extending these in vivo experiments to
from mice into non-human primates and so
on so actually we did a study with rama
mara who's also a faculty member at the
mini vaccine center and rama showed that
if you give an infusion of this blocking
antibody to monkeys that were infected
with SIV SIV
stands for simian immunodeficiency virus
it's a cousin of HIV and basically it's
the HIV virus of monkeys and what Rama
in his called his group showed is that
if you block auntie pd-1 PDL an
interaction non-human primates you get
an increase in the function of the SIV
specific t-cells and a reduction of the
virus and these in these monkeys in a
collaboration we did with with a group
in Ohio with Chris Walker
we showed the same thing in the HCV
model of chimpanzees that's really the
only model for HCV that that can be done
and then Chris showed the same thing
happening in HCV infected chimpanzees
and as I mentioned a lot of people
working in tumor models showed the same
thing and then what has been quite
amazing to see is the very very very
rapid advances that have happened in
terms of clinical trials of pd-1
in cancer patients this of course is not
our work it's we don't work on in cancer
models we actually never even worked on
a mouse cancer model okay but the real
benefit of pd-1 and the progress has
been quite remarkable has happened in
the last four three or four years and
these studies have been led by many
major pharmaceutical industries but
three in particular Merck bristol-myers
Squibb and Genentech these three big
pharmaceutical companies have developed
anti pd-1 antibodies and also anti PDL
one antibodies I told you both in a
do the same thing they block this
inhibitory interaction and release the
brake on the t-cell and the results have
been quite promising PT 1 blockade has
been shown to be effective in both phase
1 and phase 2 clinical trials for
multiple different cancers in particular
from melanoma and for lung cancer in
particular lung cancer really had hardly
any if therapy was there in terms of
chemotherapy all of that was really not
not that effective but depending on but
the PD one has given promising results
in 15 to 20% of the treated people
there's not a very large number of n but
when you go from basically no survival
zero percent survival to 15 to 20
percent there's really quite a dramatic
change in in the treatment of cancer and
within three or four years of these
human clinical trials starting both
Merck and BMS have a licensed drug so
pd-1 was licensed last year for melanoma
treatment actually fear and a half pack
for melanoma and last year also for for
lung so this has been quite remarkable
to see and I give this as an example for
how science should be done when we first
started this path down this path making
years ago 2530 years ago really was
interest was very simple we asked what
how do you maintain t-cell memory long
term we were not thinking of cancer we
were not thinking of mean therapy that
was completely out of are completely out
of our radar but these fundamental
Studies on understanding t-cell memory
led to t-cell exhaustion the t-cell
exhaustion led to the linking of pd-1
Berkeley cell exhaustion and then a
potential therapy for the rescue of
those exhausted cells and that has very
quickly brought really really work done
and the credit for this goes to the
oncologist who took these clinical
trials in different places these
companies who move things very far
forward very quickly but essentially you
now have drugs which are
effective in treating melanoma and also
in treating lung cancer
in conclusion I would like to say that
this has been a fantastic journey for us
and the wonderful team of people that
I've had in my lab that's really for me
that's one of the best things to see
these people do great work and they're
gonna move on and set up their own labs
and flourish on their own and in terms
of where we are now in terms of
understanding t-cell exhaustion and
understanding how to restore function
back and in terms of clinic I think we
still have a ways to go because we would
want to be able to get much better
response rates in the cancer patients we
want to be sure that there is durability
of the treatment that they're getting so
here would require greater understanding
of the t-cell exhaustion mechanisms I
would say maybe beyond pd-1 you know
what can you do beyond pd-1 to take it
to even to the next stage combination
therapies where these are cytokines or
other inhibitory receptors or with
therapeutic vaccinations are
possibilities but there are other ways
also there is a work that we and others
are doing looking at the epigenetic
landscape of exhausted cells and could
we change basically the insides the PD
one actually is working at the outside
well inside can we change the chromatin
of the cell can we change the epigenetic
landscape of the cell so these are not
easy to do but there are ways of doing
this there are enzymes that methylate
for example the DNA that regulates gene
expression so one we have some
preliminary data that modulating some of
these methyl transferases will change
the function of the cells so there's
very exciting and challenging things
that can be done to what I would call
changing the insides of the cell so the
goal would be release the brake and
change the insides of the cell the next
stage now is that why don't why doesn't
everyone respond why is it only that the
rates are from melanoma rates actually
are quite high in a normal response to
that as high as 40 percent response rate
and eight-state melanoma
but then you ask her what about the
other 50% why don't find well they're
not responding I think this is far as
the next challenge
are there other inhibitory receptors
that need to be identified and the comp
the right combination try or do you need
to provide some other kinds of stimulus
to do you need to combine the PD one
blockade with the therapeutic vaccine
with the vaccine against the cancer
antigen so there's a very active area of
research many companies many groups and
we're also exploring these things and
how can you take it from being 30% 40%
out to 80% or 90% that's a very very
high bar but I think that's what the
goal will be for us and for all the
other people working in this in this
area the other question is and for this
we don't have the answer yet pd-1 has
only gone into cancer patients in the
last few years and as I mentioned to you
in lung cancer the response rates are
between 20% in that range for melanoma
about 40 50 percent range 40% range but
the question is so so instead of their
survival being 3 months now they're
still alive two years or three years but
the question is how long will be the
durability of this response well they
will the cancer again come back if it
come back what the thing would be so
they're two issues that need to be
assessed how long will be the durability
of this effectiveness and how can we get
a response in the patients who don't get
the response so I think this science
here is very exciting I would encourage
any medical student who looks at this to
go into the area of cancer immunology
fascinating area where you can do basic
science and also see applications in the
clinic very quickly and again I think
the main message I want to give you is
do fundamental discovery work and that
will result in something useful